I'm a single dad and I had to go meet my
daughter's mother's new boyfriend okay
yeah oh
right and you know that's never easy but
this is my life all right this can't be
just some normal dude this guy's got to
be a cop okay yeah
but I live here like you all he can't
just be a cop this motherfucker's got to
be California Highway Patrol
he's chips y'all
chip you understand I grew up watching
chips it's a core memory for me and now
I gotta go meet Ponch what are we
talking about
hey guys I just want to say thank you
again for all the support for the
special
um continue to share it out there like
it comment on it it helps man it really
does and so many of you have asked am I
gonna sell this Lefty son hoodie and
originally I wasn't I was just using it
to promote the special but hey they're
up now on the website ryansickler.com
Lefty son hoodies are available go get
them on the website thank you for your
support you guys are the best
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it
all
rightsickler.com
all your social media uh please go watch
the special thank you for supporting it
it's out now it's on my YouTube called
Lefty son uh please go comment share it
all that good stuff
um and look subscribe to the YouTube
it's another huge way to help the show
to help everything all right and if
you've got to have more then I'm telling
you you gotta check out the patreon I
kept it at five dollars a month for
years now you get the Honeydew a day
early you get it ad free and you get it
no additional cost it's called the
Honeydew with y'all and I do this same
show with y'all that's that's what it is
it's that easy and y'all got the wildest
[__] stories I say it every week we
just talked to a kid who had a double
lung transplant
um and married his donor's girlfriend
and they're about to have a kid talk to
a kid in the Michigan State shooting who
uh barely got away we've talked to
people who've died
we've talked to so many different
honeydews out there so check it out if
you're so inclined also
um getting back to being better health
we're going to start to tour up it's
called the Ryan sickler alive oh wait no
wait I [__] it up Ryan sickler live in
a live tour
um we're starting in Fort Wayne Indiana
May 26th and 27th we're gonna hit Tacoma
June 23rd and 24th I'm in Appleton
Wisconsin July 7th and 8th and Tulsa
Oklahoma July 21st and 22nd to start all
right now also wait I do want to say
this if you're looking for a new podcast
go check out my old podcast it's called
The Crab Feast did it with Jay Larson
and uh every guest in the podcast world
that you love has come on there and has
great storytelling episodes alright so
that's the biz now you guys know what we
do over here we highlight the low lights
I always say these are the stories
behind the storytellers I I'm very
excited to have disgust on uh who I
scared the [__] out of to start this
show for the first time here ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome Josh Blue
welcome to the honeymoon you scared the
[__] out of me
are you yelling at me I just got here
dude thank you for being here first of
all
it's an honor you flew in for this yeah
man that's crazy sometimes you gotta go
have fun and do things that you know I'm
usually on the road on a Saturday like
this but this is great
well thank you for being here and before
we talk about whatever it is we're gonna
talk about
um please plug promote everything Josh
Blue yeah my social media is just Josh
Blue comedy it's basically my name and
then what I do and uh
it's uh pretty simple Josh Blue on all
social media social media and then if
you can follow me on YouTube that'd be
great and all that other [__] check
out your special oh yeah somebody I just
filmed my fifth hour special and I'm not
sure where it's coming out exactly but
it's coming yeah I just did my first in
a year you've got five already and I
have the CD too it says six hours of
recorded materials pretty [__] cool
to say man it feels good and you know
just it it's a fun process for sure well
you've also we were talking you said
you've been Road dogging for 20 years 20
years 20 years yeah and I do like 200
shows a year that's insane so I was like
flying on average every three days
usually which is Bonkers Bonkers but I
love it I love making people laugh it
feels [__] good really I mean I know
you know that just it feels good and
like laughing feels good but making
people laugh it's that same like
endorphins and just like this is what's
more fun than this right
um well let's talk about everything
because uh you're born with Cerebral
Palsy yeah we'd like to get that out of
the way early let's just get that out of
the way early but is that is that
something that's genetic like do any of
your parents have that no it's uh any
brothers and sisters no it's not genetic
it's basically like a brain injury at
Birth or lack of oxygen I was actually
born in Cameroon West Africa really and
my parents were teaching over there and
then
I just I didn't want to come out so
basically I was in utero for like 10
months and then they finally had to do
an emergency C-section and it didn't go
well
it didn't go quite as they had helped
and now I walk like this
he's such a hell of an explanation yeah
and I was meddy backed out of Cameroon
on my second day of life I flew around
the world to New York holy [__] and I
have a passport like my dad carried me
in a wicker basket and they never they
they never even looked in the bed is
that real they smuggled me in they
didn't I didn't cry I mean I thought I
was dead
is that baby dead yeah all right you can
bring them in put them on the scanner
he's fine
so you're born in Africa yeah and then
two days later you're into New York to
get medical help is that where your
family was from or is that just where
the best hospitals the best closest
thing that they could get to okay
um I grew up in Minnesota so but yeah
and then my parents were there for two
years and then I got medical attention
alphabet from my mom too because there's
no phones and [__] Cameroon so she
just thought I was dead like lying up
wait so just your dad took you yeah I
know and a nurse because the C-section
in
Africa is not I mean the babies come and
get the shovel
yeah yeah
it's not good so my poor mom was like
you know she couldn't try she couldn't
go and they sent like a nurse with my
dad
and what year are you born uh 78. so
your mom's just laying there thinking
her baby is dead right and then I think
two weeks later my dad showed back up
with with little me so what happened in
New York I don't know they gave me some
vitamins made it work and then you go
back to camera stabilize me got me back
and then and how long are you guys in
Africa before your family comes and are
you an only child by the way no I'm the
youngest of four four okay which I have
an interesting theory about that so none
of my other siblings have any
disabilities that we talk about
[Music]
you're transparent with your [__] but I
feel very fortunate you know like having
Cerebral Palsy being the fourth child I
really think that was to my benefit
because if I was the first child you
know when you have a kid you don't know
what the [__] you're doing you're
overprotective mother you're not serious
so there's you know they would have been
so protective of me I wouldn't have been
able to grow and do what I'm able to do
whereas being the fourth child by the
time they got to me they're like ah [__]
it he's fine he's fine
it's no big deal whatever so yeah so
youngest of four
um and so when does your family leave
Africa and head back to the U.S how are
you I think I was about one when we came
back and then we I went to elementary
school in Minnesota and then when I was
15 we moved to Senegal West Africa for a
whole year and I lived over there what
was it about Africa that your parents
like so much so my dad is
my dad speaks 13 languages are you
serious yeah damn Super Genius
um
he's a language Professor taught French
and wolf and do you know all the
languages so I that he speaks yeah I can
recite him but does he do any like
Chinese man none of that it's more
romance languages and like he taught
French and Italian I was just about to
say Italian French Spanish
and then uh in Senegal the native
language is wolof and he speaks that I
speak that as well do you really pretty
pretty well actually do you blow mines
over there I blow mines
oh
wow so hard will tell me about a time
where you just blew someone's mouth or
like what because you probably have a
good accent and everything so yeah so
I've been told that I was the best
non-native speaker that people have ever
heard so I'm not my dad's better
grammatically and like maybe vocabulary
but I can speak it like a [__]
let's hear something it's just it's a
very playful language
hey yo what are you doing Alyssa you
want me to blow people's minds there's
uh you know when you go to New York City
the vendors that I always have the
knockoff watches those are all
Senegalese dudes they're like the
vendors of the world and any big city
they'll be trying to sell you a
knock-off purse and when I talk wolves
to them they're like who is this
homeless guy speaking my language this
is [__] insane dude I would love to
watch that all day why aren't you doing
that it's so fun people they like jump
out of their skin and they hear me and
I'm like I said I'm good at it it's just
like I've watched this video of this
really white dude who does that in China
but it's a very specific dialect
and he'll sit there and speak English
first and then he'll just casually drop
something off the menu and they just
they just you just see him stop like
what and people are turning like holy
[__] it's like that so I I
I feel like whatever my dad's gift of
language I have it my siblings have we
all speak at least three languages I
speak French pretty fluently as well
um but yeah so that's Africa to me is
really uh influential time when I was I
turned 16 in Senegal and because you
know that's a really pretty
um yes what we're going to talk about
yeah you know that that time of your
life is you're seeing the world and and
like I was super down about having
Cerebral Palsy when I was a kid and I
went to Senegal and I was like
[__] it I'm so lucky to have what I have
and it just it changed my perspective of
wow what this was and that like even
though I you know walk like this at
least I got some [__] shoes you know
I got you know food to eat like you just
put it in
it just clicked it in yeah and ever
since then I just was this
happy go lucky dude to just here to have
fun and make people laugh and well you
do some you travel so I'm look I know
what traveling's like it's a pain in the
ass for everybody and you say you're out
doing 200 shows a year 200. so
you know you said to learn what this is
what is this what's the hardest part
about having Cerebral Palsy for you well
you know what's really interesting with
that question is this is all that I've
ever known so I don't know anything
different so like this is just my life
that I deal with on a daily basis and it
like you know I you know
my fine motor skills are [__] bro like
you know you want me to carry a pot of
hot soup and go [__] yourself
I'm gonna pass on that we're gonna eat
the soup over here yeah
[Music]
I made the soup can you come get it if
you want it
ha
[__] it's self-serve here
the pot is on the stove
oh okay that's interesting it's a great
answer to that question yeah it sums up
it sums it up you know and and again
I've had this my whole life I've
definitely come to terms with like what
it is and I still get mad at myself for
dropping something and and people like
give yourself a [__] break like it's
not your fault that you and I'm like
well I'm pretty high too though
ha
my first uh comedy Like official show I
did in college and I put flyers all over
it and said it's not the palsy it's the
pot that's great that's great my
professor was like we know all right so
um it's all you've known your whole life
um what's your first job my first job I
worked uh at a camp I was a camp
counselor I had a really primitive
camp in like Northern Minnesota it was a
camp for inner city Youth and I actually
attended the camp Oh no okay it was you
know I think my parents just didn't know
what the [__] to do with me during the
summer like hey go to this ghetto camp
and uh it was great I fit right in that
[__] and I went to Camp two
years in a row and then they're like you
need to come work for us so then that
was my first job and you know can you
imagine inner city youth coming and I'm
their counselor like ah I'm chop tall
nice to meet you are you gonna be my
canoe buddy you want me to get on a boat
with this one
if I'm the guy taking you canoeing for
three days
no no
we're going like 40 miles on the river
holy [__] and you're you're camping out
overnight and stuff yeah man and you're
on you're by yourself so there's me and
like a counselor and an assistant
counselor with how many kids eight okay
that's a lot of kids that's a good
amount of kids you know I make canoes
there's four canoes all right it could
be more like up to 12 which was a lot of
[__] kids to keep track of but
because they don't know [__] about them
Woods I would be like you know it's
getting dark out the walls are coming up
better get in here oh [__] I'm getting
the tender
um the question I want to ask you is
this
basically
what's it like when people treat you
differently because you have cerebral
palsy and it's a two-part question and
if you ever had someone in your life
that didn't and you were like [__] thank
you thank you for just treating me like
a [__] regular person like I'm I am
yeah I mean
the first part of the question I mean it
it's annoying as hell to have people
just see the way you move and then just
assume that you're also
mentally disabled or I mean people often
think I'm like a crazy crazy homeless
person and I'm dressed nicely but people
still will like give me a wide berth on
the sidewalk and [__] and I'm like I can
see
I can see you [__] like I see
you move what's that joke I said uh I'll
be coming down the street and how I say
uh chivalry isn't dead because when I
see a couple walking down the street
towards me the man will move his lady to
the safe side and I'm like there ain't
no safe side I'm gonna get your lady
uh
uh yeah that's that's stuff they deal
with and I mean I can't count the number
of times I've been 86 from a bar before
I've even like had one drink people be
like they'll be like get the [__] out of
here you're wasted and I mean it's great
because my friends will be like actually
he has cerebral palsy and then they're
like I'm so sorry here's a free beer
like
that's that's how I drank my way through
most events it's just like guilting
people into it guilty of them yeah
um but that that stuff is like I can see
it I get it it's a bar situation I look
something's obviously wrong uh you'd
assume that it's more of things like
I've gone into hotels that I was staying
at and one time I was waiting for my
ride and the manager came up and was
like what are you doing in here I'm like
waiting for my ride dude he's like get
the [__] out of here and he made me get
out of the hotel and I was like I'm a
guest here and I showed him
my room key and he was still like get
the [__] up like like I had found a room
key in the right yeah right yeah yeah I
mean I I almost sued those people yeah
it was like [__] yeah like you [__]
I'm clearly he even looked at the lady
at the desk like is he staying here and
she was like yes and he still was like
get up it was insane
so the that there's that's there's that
kind of
um things where it's more about the
visual when I get mad more is the mental
stuff so my biggest thing okay well in
in this comedy career right
people
still only see me as the cerebral palsy
comic and it's I'm a comedian that
happens to have cerebral palsy and I
talk about it because this is what I
know yeah like and people talk about
their marriages their [__]
mybringings all that erased their right
body type sexual preference all that so
I'm doing the same thing and for some
reason
everyone that you talk too much about
that I'm like
this is what I [__] know I tried to
do it from a Southern bell point of view
but that didn't work
haven't been mad
Mr Earl uh no but who tells you that uh
I've gotten it
um well okay so this is like just over
the years like I mean Netflix has told
me that like uh
um all right how about this so hold on
Netflix told you that you talk too much
about having Cerebral Palsy man [__]
Netflix [__] Netflix for real if if any
one of those people excuse me had uh
were seven foot tall they'd be talking
about what life is like to be eight feet
tall or nine feet tall if they were
missing their legs they'd be talking
about how their life is missing legs and
the thing is I look at it like if you
have that point of view of me you're not
watching my show because yes it comes
from a vessel that is disabled but I'm
talking about other [__] in this body
you know it's not just like
yeah it's it's real [__] that happens
day to day all right so this one is the
one that gets me the most tired up and
angry about this
business all right so
I had never been to the Montreal
Festival like everybody that was on last
Comic went to the festival and they
didn't invite me and they didn't invite
me
they finally invited me in
2019 I think
and you know and one last time I was six
I know I can't believe it's been that
long we were talking about it before it
is yeah I thought it was like 10 years
ago yeah and they finally invited me to
the thing I was so ecstatic and my agent
was there and I was sitting with her I
was like so why did it take this long 13
years to get me into this Festival
and she said
their response was we just don't know
where he would fit into our Festival
and I'm like what does that even
like people that like to laugh I don't
uh and then she basically was like he
opens for Ron White he opens for Dave
Chappelle like the two huge names that
like like this guy enough to open for
and they finally got me in
uh I heard that I was like I'm gonna
show you where I [__] fit in yeah and
I did the um William H Macy Gala and uh
I got a standing ovation on my 10 minute
set [__] yeah dude and I came off stage
and I'm like I'm like that's why I
[__] fit in and then a big wig from
the festival comes over and he goes past
me on the head and goes you're so
courageous
and I do you know who it was tell me
yeah I don't I don't know but I almost
punched this old man in his [__] face
and I'm like I get goosebumps I get like
oh I'm like even talking about this I
get so [__] and reads and I mean did
anyone was anyone there that heard that
what did you say what'd you do you I
physically stopped myself from pushing
an old man down and I walked the [__]
away and I was like so courageous and
it was in that moment or like since
processing that I'm like this business
is never gonna see me as a comedian that
just got a standing ovation in a big
theater but here's the thing about it
the business doesn't need to anymore
right the people need to that's it these
people right here these fans these great
people and the people know that that's
my family become an applauded that
[__] clowned it right but it just
made me realize that anything I want to
do in this business is gonna have to be
me doing it I'm not waiting for them to
go okay now but yeah it doesn't happen
for most of most people it doesn't I'm
telling you bro every time now that I
filmed the special or to have something
big to do I think about that moment in
my head right before I do it because I
get [__] yeah I'm gonna show you
[__]
I'ma start thinking about that yeah
I'm a grown [__] man what are you
doing so courageous
blood boil I'm so mad so that's those
are the moments in my life that are like
I still really feel the impact of being
disabled and like
I I'm very happy got lucky but then when
those things happen it's just such a
reality check to make the life and [__]
like that
and again I do live this really weird
dual life where I'm a pretty famous
comedian
walking down the street and people stop
me for that and then two steps later
like get away from me you drunk ass
[__] that yeah he's taking pictures of
people and then they want you to [__]
yeah exactly it's crazy man all right so
um I want to talk more about this
because you're a parent you're a dad dad
and what age do you get
um did you get married first I did well
one of them was on the way okay yeah so
um how do you and your your wife at the
time meet uh I was dating her friend nah
I pulled the old Switcheroo
and then you started dating her yeah and
then married her yeah
first that's why we got married I didn't
really I shouldn't have got married no
no why
uh I think it's a weird uh Union of an
idea and kind of Arcane I agree it is it
is an archaic [__]
oh [__] made more sense when you like
lived on the Prairie and there wasn't
another person in 50 miles yeah I guess
I'm with you yeah but uh yeah so uh when
we had so two kids
um I love being a dad I actually I I
like babies man I like riddles yeah cute
ass babies I make people nervous as hell
they're like hey didn't everybody tell
you not to shake a baby I'm like I'm
just holding it
it's like
oh dude
somebody arrested
um all right talk talk to me about the
challenges of being a dad with cerebral
palsy like uh do do you drive I don't
you don't so that's number one challenge
that's a big challenge yeah I don't
drive uh you know I'm beside rely on
others to help get them to school and
all that [__] so
um and then again it's interesting
because
this is all that my kids have ever known
just like this is all I've ever known so
it's just how daddy does it or I was
really active and like you [__] do it
like make the kids do it and so now they
work for me
so that's right how are they now 15 and
my daughter's almost 13. definitely old
enough to be yeah yeah so but they've
been doing [__] for me since they were
two like you go get that
no the Budweiser Budweiser read it
um
yeah so again you know we're not eating
soup at the table unless they carry uh
no so yeah I mean cooking I cook I do
everything I do the laundry I do it all
but I definitely make them help
so good yeah but driving is the biggest
issue I have
um I wanted to talk to you about this
too because it's very something very
interesting you did play sports and
stuff and you were a soccer player yeah
it says on the U.S paralympic team for
eight years I've been there a while
eight countries playing soccer for the
US how did we do believe suck
who's the best paralympic uh Team
country time it was uh Russia or Ukraine
wow okay I'll see I would have thought
South America and Brazil well Brazil was
up there but the Russians were like
mechanical palsy machines
I've never seen it man I was we were
better that good we lost to them 11-1
[Laughter]
and and the one was them scoring on
their own
we got borders shooting on their goalie
let's take some real shots
they're that good huh I'm telling you
one time I forget I think it was in the
old four Paralympics in Athens I was on
the field this I was trying to cover
this dude he was running down the right
wing and he got a ball over his shoulder
like somebody just booted it any one
time no kicked it into the back of our
goal and I was like Nice Shot man like a
high five in the [__] other teams
coach does not like that you do that
yeah we we got smoke bro they're so good
but it was such an amazing experience
and I also think that was a really
pivotal point in my life of being
comfortable in this body and like
getting to hang out with other
physically disabled dudes that have been
through some of the same [__] and
and also you're you're a team yeah
literally it's outside of the cerebral
palsy you're also a team you're coming
together like that so that's [__]
great so I think that really helped me
with my comedy because those two things
were taken off at the same time like
within one month I started like getting
some Traction in comedy and then all of
a sudden I join the National Team it's
like going to one month I was like
were you a soccer player like all your
life
I honestly I've never been on a team
before that nah that's the first time
you played organized soccer was for the
goddamn Olympic team
um so I tried out and I I mean I tried
out in junior high and they [__] cut
me and it broke my heart and like all I
gotta say is like in junior high
let me come to practice you know what I
mean you don't need it's Junior yeah
everyone should play in June you don't
need to cut me let me at least come and
and so that kind of discouraged me from
ever like trying out for
the college team or anything but I
always bought a soccer ball with me
everywhere I went over just juggle and
dribble it and I just got really good on
the ball and then I I just found out I
didn't even know the Paralympics were a
thing and then so yeah how do you um
what what is it what does it involved to
uh try out for them basically this girl
gave me a email of the coach she's like
she's saw me juggling she had palsy
she's a swimmer and she goes you know
there's a soccer team for you right and
I was like no what are you talking about
she goes yeah and she had the coaches
emailing like a gum wrapper and I was so
nervous to email him I carried it around
for like three months before I got the
balls to just do like that right I said
and the email is uh my name is Josh Blue
I'm 22 years old I have cerebral palsy
and I'm a damn good soccer player and he
wrote back nice to meet you Josh Blue
where I was looking for damn good soccer
players
and then two weeks later I'm on a plane
to DC to the uh it was just one of their
camps but it was a tryout for me and uh
ever since then I was either a starter
or the first Sub in so I was my
endurance is [__] because I'm a partier
uh
but I'm I bring like the morale up when
I come on I'm I play soccer with my
elbows you know like you come by me I'm
gonna [__] sting you does the coach
also have cerebral palsy no he's just a
[__] witch how do we feel about that
um it was fine he was actually uh
there's two different coaches we went
through but the the one I had longest
was actually the assistant coach for the
Women's National Team oh okay back in
the day so here's a real deal yeah a
real deal level coach he's a real prick
but
liquid IV is the category winning
hydration brand fueling your well-being
and their hydration multiplier is the
one product you're missing in your daily
routine in just one stick you're getting
five essential vitamins and two times
faster hydration than water alone use it
first thing in the morning use it before
a workout when you feel run down after a
long night out and on Long flights I'm
taking them on my flights right now and
your boys in physical therapy right now
and I take my water every day to
physical therapy with a liquid IV in it
12 delicious refreshing flavors to keep
your hydration routine exciting contains
five essential vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 and
vitamin C has three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks and it's made with premium
ingredients non-GMO and free from gluten
dairy and soy grab your liquid IV and
bulk nationwide at Costco or you can get
20 off when you go to liquid iv.com and
use code honeydew at checkout that's 20
off of anything you order when you shop
better hydration today using promo code
honeydew at liquid iv.com our next
partner is athletic greens I heard about
athletic greens and decided to give them
a try because I wanted to improve my gut
health and get my immune system some
extra support especially after getting
out of the damn hospital it's all your
key Health Products like multivitamins
minerals pre and probiotics and more
working together as one I added ag1 in
my morning routine and it really does
leave me feeling like I'm doing
something good for my body it's made
with 75 high quality vitamins minerals
and Whole Food sourced ingredients that
deliver benefits like mood immune system
and sleep support sustained energy and
so much more you can even get it in
convenient travel packs for when you're
on the go like I'm going to use for my
upcoming tour so if you want to take
ownership of your health today is a good
time to start athletic greens is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase go to athletic green dot
com slash honeydew that's athletic
greens.com
honeydew check it out
let's get back to the do um all right I
want to ask you this because you said
the Russians were like palsy robots or
whatever
um fastest dude with cerebral palsy
you've seen and like I mean with just
hauling ass oh man my buddy
you like long distance wise he can do
um like a five minute mile
oh
my God he's insane dude uh that's like
long distance
um I was one of the fastest people on
the team for like the 40 15 yards
[Music]
real fast
that's just a burst yeah yeah I got a
quick burst that's all I need because I
was a cherry picker you know no outside
so like I was I was able to get to the
ball like you take a shot and it squirts
out I'll just get to it first but much
after that I'm like I'm out uh there's a
guy on my team
and then Martel
I mean the way he walked his feet were
like pigeon toed in so far and you're
like there's no way this guy can play
soccer he was a [__] Phenom I've
never seen those [__] like that he's
like doing bicycle kicks and [__] I'm
like damn when he came on the team I was
like well I guess I'm out
there goes my spot you took my spot for
sure and they were not wrong to give it
to him he's [__] good and then my um
the captain of the team Josh McKinney he
was my best friend on the team he has
the most goals in international play of
any uh US men's team damn is that right
he's like
98 or something which is a lot of
[__] goals in international play all
right you were eight years you said on
the team so in all the eight years tell
me wherever it was whatever country
who's the best player you remember
period like just like Jesus Christ is
there a guy you think that could play
not in the national team or whatever but
in a with yeah people who don't have
cerebral palsy I mean we most of my
teammates we could hang with like
non-polsy people I play with I mean I
played with that I'm telling you that
guy Martel dude he was the best national
athlete and like he get in goal and you
couldn't score on the [__] guy either
but he could also kick the [__] out of a
ball he had accuracy and touch he could
Juke you out you're like how are you
your feet are on backwards like your
feet are all back I think that's how he
did it
that would definitely make me feel like
hey I can't tell me this game
[Laughter]
no there's some really amazing players
out there that you're like
I mean there's this one Brazilian dude
he must have had a stroke or something
because his right side or was like
pretty puny but his left side was like
the incredible it was weird as [__] he
had the biggest limp in his run and when
he would kick the ball with his Hulk leg
it was scary like I'd just get out of
the way to the ball like I'm the good
you go ahead and score
it's amazing the different levels of
like just
what people can overcome honestly also
I'm sitting here thinking about it
because it's interesting like each
person has something inside them whether
it's god-given ability for athletics or
music or whatever right and you're
telling me cerebral palsy it's not a
genetic thing it's because something
happens so this person who's about to
come out and be born already has this
inherent god-given talent for whatever
it is but then cerebral palsy makes it
way more difficult yeah so this guy
you're telling me about this athlete
this dude if if he didn't have cerebral
palsy it sounds like he probably could
play on the actual national team yeah I
believe that I mean he was [__]
interesting [__] I've never even it's
a weird weird mind conundrum we're like
wait what how does this work again when
you saw the guy walking you're like
there's no way this guy could play
soccer and he's
so good so good uh it's a it's really
interesting to see disabled sport I
think a lot of times it doesn't get the
credit
that it deserves because I'm like yeah
anybody can run with two legs
not everybody unfortunately so people
don't know
you're making us look man oh yeah uh but
I've always been a athlete like I'm I I
took great pride in like
humiliating able-bodied people in sport
like I used to play a street football as
a kid that was my jam and I was one of
the best wide receivers in the
neighborhood
I was fast as [__] and they're just like
I just get this 15 yards and gone 15 man
hit me number 15. and I'm out of here
I'm done and uh
I mean I would Juke the [__] out of kids
and and that was also the fun thing like
if any new kids would come to the
neighborhood and they'd be playing with
us they'd be like why'd you pick that
guy first they're like you'll see
five touchdowns later I'm like high
stepping into the end zone like haha
kid man
all right I want to um
I want to switch gears for a second
because I also want to ask I saw the our
little list up here um the hotel
incident Montreal is that though is that
what the the dude saying you're so
courageous yeah the the Montreal thing
yeah but the hotel is just the guy
kicking me out you know oh yeah throwing
it yeah yeah like I just want to make
sure we got that because what I I do
want to talk about because this is I
mean look we record these podcasts ahead
of time obviously just so the fans know
and um this just happened so
um there your son was involved in the
the most recent Denver school shooting
yep East High School it happened last
Wednesday that's where he right now
we're recording on a Saturday so this
was literally what three four days ago
this happened so
look at the you know text message
school's in lockdown and then turn on
the news and it's like
shooting at the school the Kid shot
two deans that were conducting a pat
down on the child and then he produced a
gun shot them both and then fled and
then
um there was a you know there man
hunting for the kid and
he was found dead the next day he killed
himself up in the mountains so
it's really I mean I don't know what the
[__] to do man like what what are we
doing here what what is happening oh I
just saw that reporter and it was her
son that had was coming up right there
at the time and then um and Kirsten she
said her husband knows one of the dean's
uh he's in critical condition right now
yeah it's [__] insane like and I just
saw this video I don't know where it was
maybe an Alabama school or something but
it's the it's a bulletproof like barrier
and it's over in the corner it's like a
two-wall thing that goes and the teacher
has to grab it the kids get it pulled
out and then the kids all have to run
like what the [__] what are we doing I
mean I appreciate the effort but there's
got to be something that can prevent you
needing that
and is this kid a student at that school
he was a student of the school and he
already
for whatever reason in order for him to
come into school he had to get a pat
down every day which I have questions on
that alone like wait why are we
giving him a chance if he's already got
to that level and then this is what
happens
and then uh less than a month before
that there was another shooting at the
same school and less than a month and
the kid was sitting in his car at lunch
break
car pulled up shot him drove away
they're still at large I believe so they
don't even know if they were actual
students of the school or anything and
then the kid was in a coma for two weeks
and then he died and then this happened
a week later so a week after this poor
kid dies from the last school shooting
you have another school shooting and the
kids walked out of school the day of his
death did a March to the capital all
that and then the next week this happens
again so I'm just I'm at a point where
it's just like what what
what is going to be done about this what
why why are we letting this happen in
our society to our [__] children of
all things I don't at the place they're
supposed to be these kids aren't out
doing [__] that's wrong or [__] they're
at school right and they're also Sitting
Ducks I just on my patreon I was telling
you I talked to a guy who just was in
the Michigan State shooting that was
just I mean that was only a few weeks
ago around Valentine's Day that was and
um he's laying behind a Podium watching
the wood chips fly off and he's like
this is going to be how I die and two
kids two girls I think he said in his
class did die
um so it's just happening it's such a
rapid pace and now you're now when
people say you know the such and such
school shooting people's response is
which one is that because they're so
[__] many of them well I think this
is the thing that ultimately Disturbed
me the most about this is that my son
seems fine
which is great but the fact that he's so
numb to this happening he's not even
like
he's like yeah
I asked him I was like hey do you want
to be homeschooled do you want to go to
a private school he's like no I don't I
want to stay here and like
I love that in them but I'm also like
this isn't affecting you like what
there's just too many of these it's just
has there been a meeting from this with
the school yet or anything where the
parents can go like a town hall where
the parents can come in and just [__]
rip them alive now yeah I'm sure but
what I mean again what's that gonna do
they said they're gonna have two police
officers at every school now
two two uh at every entrance or just two
at the whole [__] school again your
gun is
a gun it shoots very fast that's right
so I don't know I mean it's it's too
little too late you know
it's just and again
you hear about this every day but then
when it it happens at your kids school
that [__] makes you angry and yeah
what changed what what are we gonna do
about that there's no our politicians
they're never gonna
make this change I don't know what
makes me want to shoot somebody
[Music]
it's like [__] God damn it man I mean I
you know you know how it works until
someone in power has it touched them
right until it affects them personally
then [__] doesn't get done if God forbid
that happens to the president's son or
anybody like in power like that then
[__] will start to change you know but
it's just happening to regular people
and what are we gonna do that's not our
problem right not our problem we're over
here
anyway that's
it's
it's a process now it's like making sure
my son is mentally okay after that
because you can also say you're okay and
not be okay so
you know but now my daughter is supposed
to go to that school in a couple years
and it was a great school it's it's one
of the best schools in Colorado and
that's happening there so
go
it's the same like I can't I'm just
trying to put my head in your son's uh
place like imagine being in [__] what
is he 10th grade 15. ninth grade and two
[__] one's enough to traumatize you
forever two in not ninth grade and then
my senior year [__] back to back
include a month within a month right
so just and then the other thing is like
I say we do take them out of school well
do we also not go to movie theaters or
grocery stores or malls or because it's
happening every [__] place
you can't go outside without a person
got a gun is that person you know I'm as
you see I'm already a jumpy [__]
you do get a little excited yeah that's
a palsy thing it says we have Wicked
startle reflex oh really yeah so but you
get a gun involved I'll fly out the roof
uh so you you are divorced I'm divorced
and you yeah thank you you have you have
split custody 50 so how
um how do you manage that with the road
and stuff you go home you see the kids
so we made it pretty cool so three weeks
a month I have them
Sunday through Wednesday and then I can
travel Thursday through Sunday okay and
then one week a month I have them for
the whole week so I take a week off the
road and hang out with the kids yeah
unless something better comes up well
you said you love being a dad I do man
what do you love about it
I've always wanted to be a dad like when
I was a kid but yeah like what do you
want to be when you grow up I want to be
a dad I was never sure about the husband
part but
um
the again babies were my jam I just love
that age obviously this is teenage years
it's coming with some real [__] to to
parent on
um but my kids are great it's funny
engaging human beings that uh you know
can talk to adults look them in the eye
like I'm proud of that [__] you know I
made two little smart funny [__] go
for you dude yeah they're good
my daughter's sense of humor is evil bro
she's she's something here
I had a buddy come over it was a
triple amputee is a vet what's what is
what is the triple amputee what is he
missing uh both legs above the knee and
then one arm and then he's out like a
couple fingers on the other hand he came
over as a comedian my daughter I mean we
had to carry him in the house put his
wheelchair down your daughter did that
one no no no okay the other comedian and
then my daughter comes in the room when
he's there and she looks them up and
down she goes ah finally someone I'm
taller than
no
no oh my God
[Laughter]
oh yeah this purple
he literally games yes he gave almost
all of it
finally an adult I'm taller than oh
all right so what age do you start doing
comedy and why what what got you into
comedy were you always a comedy fan as
well listening to different comedians or
did you just go say [__] it and try it
so I always loved laughing and love
stand up I felt like
you don't know that's a real thing that
you can do as a kid you just see people
and you're like wow that's [__]
amazing I remember stealing uh Eddie
Murphy cassette tape from my buddy's
brother and like giggling uncontrollably
and not even really getting the jokes he
just said rubber penis and I was like oh
you know yeah it was just giggling so
hard and I just loved stand up and like
I mean this is a hard one but I I
remember watching [__] Bill Cosby
right and our teacher put it on in high
school class The Bill Cosby himself and
I remember watching it and for some
reason I was just like I could do that
and like not many people watching the
amazing comedian and just go yeah I
could do that and I just it was in my
head since that and then I went to a
really liberal arts college called The
Evergreen State College in Washington
and you can create your own courses and
majors and I actually studied stand up
my senior year I got credit for it and
um never looked back
so yeah I just I've always been quick
quick with it and had the impeccable
timing and where did you uh do your
first spot
in Minnesota when you were in Minnesota
no I mean the first spots were on the
campus of the University or the college
but then my first Club I played was the
Tacoma underground it was like back in
the day and
um so again I'll give you a taste of it
so be you know my first set they gave me
two minutes I met the host for like one
second before he asked me what my intro
was and he goes on and it turns out he's
a cop
comic which is not a thing and all the
jokes were like I pulled the guy over
and then I hit him in the head with my
billy club like what it's not funny like
and then he did his set and then
he said okay are you ready for our first
comedian
he's a very special guy
he's a good friend of mine please
welcome Josh Blue and I went up I was
like I don't know that [__]
[Laughter]
but that was my instant like first taste
of like this condescending [__] guy
like he's a special guy yeah he's a good
friend of mine like don't talk down to
me you know have you gotten a lot of
that in comedy for sure yeah and you
know here's the thing I get the most and
I actually really enjoy it it's like
I'll come into a room and
you don't know me like last night
there's a lot of comics at the club that
didn't know me and I'm like super
friendly I'm like a golden retriever I
want to talk to everybody say hello get
to know you a little bit I'm the
opposite I'm the opposite yeah I just
like doing it it's just fun and and
these people wouldn't even get like look
at me I'm like hey how's it going I try
to shake their hand and be like just
treating me like some
and then I went on and [__] murdered
and then they come up like hey it's nice
to meet you I'm like [__] off you're
addicted to me beforehand like what why
is it now that you see that I'm better
than you
at this I don't know it
I don't like that kind of [__] it really
irks me because I I got that my whole
career like people just assuming
promoters and Club managers and all that
[__] too but then I go do it and they're
like oh whoops whoops yeah just go slay
so I [__] I love it I love playing
man do most people treat you differently
at first and then what you crush and
then they switch gears
I mean at this point I have enough clout
and credit that that like you know
anywhere I'm going is I sold out the
theater for him so they're like okay
this guy's gotta be and you know I'm
represented well so they weed out most
of the [__] but some still gets
through
um I wanted to ask you about your
parents growing up and I know you said
you're the youngest uh and you have
cerebral palsy but what did they did
they try to raise you in a way where
they didn't treat you any differently
than your other siblings just so you got
used to real [__] life that was it
they just treated me like another just
another kid like they my mom said this
like yeah you had
um some needs that the other kids didn't
have but it was like we're taking
heard a soccer practice and you to
therapy it's just like the thing we did
for you it wasn't like and they never
made it a big deal and they and like you
know they made me do
chores and all that [__] but I mean you
can ask my siblings they're like you
didn't do [__]
right doing
didn't have anything to do with the
palsy they're like you could do this I'm
like I could but I'm not going to you
know
um so they definitely just tried to make
it as as normal as possible but also I
was the first one of the first disabled
kids to go through the public school
system
mainstream like I was in special ed till
of fourth grade and like you know you
know and in special ed back then they
just clumped us all together so you'd be
with the Down Syndrome kid and then the
the blind kid and they kind of treat us
all the same but then we got to fourth
grade me and my buddy Nick who had palsy
and
they're like you know we gotta let these
guys go
we got a mainstream Straight A's yeah
yeah
and then
and then they let us out into General
pop and we went you know but there was a
lot of learning for the teachers because
all of a sudden these teachers that have
taught a certain way their whole career
now we come in and we need to be we need
different
uh you know we could still do the work
but we got to the answer in a different
route if that makes sense so I just
remember my mom having to go to school
and I mean I I bet she made a lot of my
teachers cry like just like listen just
chew them out like [__] hell like
just he's smart he's smarter than the
other kids just he can't write he can't
my writing is [__] so I actually had to
have a a scribe this is super
interesting so like through Elementary
School they just had another kid right
for me so basically we just take the
test together and then I'd be like what
do you think you know like are you
serious so then in junior high they got
me uh my own scribe her name was Rosa
Marie Daniels is she like an older a
high school kid or college kid or
something or middle age middle-aged
black woman from Mississippi
oh that's awesome I went from Junior
High through high school with with Miss
Daniels it was like going to school with
my big black mom
it was insane bro she would just sit
right next to me
in the desk next to me
she I didn't even know
dude it was it was insane it was and she
dressed like she's going to church every
day like big hats hats in the schools
no nobody [__] with me man
we're not invested like a that is too
was she friendly did you grow did you
have a relationship I mean she's a sweet
lady she ever reach out to you when when
you guys we actually talk on Instagram
for real to this day hell yeah all right
yeah great woman did you ever ask her
what do you think she just
like oh yeah she would help she would
dude I don't know anything I don't know
[__] she knows everything man I remember
one time the teacher moved us into his
office because I couldn't be doing the
answers in front of when they're taking
the exam oh yeah yeah so he put us in
the office and the [__] answer key
was on the desk and I was like is it B
she's like
I just think she was doing it because
she's like I can't have this guy repeat
a grade yeah with him anymore uh man she
was she was great I remember too like
looking back on this I'm like oh I get
it now my teachers were scared of her
like I remember one time she was
painting her fingernails in class
you know how bad that smells yeah the
teacher came he was like who's painting
their fingernail who's doing and then he
saw her and he was like
[Music]
just just a proud amazing woman like
just held herself strong and like I
remember one time she was tapping her
nails
and I was like are you bored and she
goes yeah I already went to high school
oh [__] you're right this must be so
boring following my dumb ass around
pretty cool but it was pretty cool yeah
I attribute a lot of My Success to her
too do you just because it was it was
like having a very proper religious
person on your shoulder and making sure
you're not being she kept you in line
yeah she didn't just help with school
she like yeah you know and like any
other kid but that's the thing I was I
always had the timing my timing's always
been good so I'll just wait for it in
class for the teacher to say something
and I'll just drop something in and make
all the kids laugh and the teachers
laugh you make her laugh too sometimes
yeah she was a tough audience now what
was she what if you're out sick that day
do you have to give her a heads up so
she doesn't show up oh yeah for sure
we'd tell her but then also like she
would be out sick some days so those
would be like days off well in school
still because I'm like free day I can't
do anything
I'm sorry I would but I was can't right
dude listen this has been a great
episode
um thank you very much for coming on
here thanks for having me dude I I enjoy
this well I'm gonna ask you one last
question and it really lines up because
you said 16 was a very pivotal time for
you because I think you back in Senegal
then yeah so what advice would you give
to your 16 year old self
I think it was just like
it's gonna be okay
I think I had so many worries about like
a girl's gonna like me because of the
way I walk and like that was a lot of
anxiety and I just I think if I was 16
and I knew like listen dude it's gonna
work out the way it's supposed to and
like don't stress that [__] it would
have saved me a lot of anxiety through
those years
um
yeah it's it's gonna work out that's
great dude thank you for doing this
seriously my pleasure man um promote
everything again you're special all of
it yeah just Josh Blue Comedy All social
media Instagram Twitter blah blah blah
blah I hate this [__] and uh a YouTube
channel and then oh also um I have
Edibles in Colorado so
um uh it's in Colorado and Missouri now
so in over a hundred uh dispensaries
throughout the country it's called Josh
Blue's dream that's in Colorado's
Joshua's dream and then in Missouri it's
called Josh Blue's marijuana dream all
right and uh they're edible suckers four
flavors I recommend the sour pineapple
you got a honeydew in common oh yeah we
should I'll talk to the boys about it
all right thank you again uh as always
Ryan sickler on all social media Ryan
sickler.com we'll talk to you all next
week
all right
[Music]
foreign